bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi à 4
avril près de 1000 artistes ont investi
le grand palais à paris parmi eux un
élan courtois nicolas sanhes exposé
l'une de ses oeuvres art paris art fair
il défie les lois de la physique johann
le guillerm propose avec ce secret temps
d'une réflexion philosophique sur
l'équilibré le pas grand chose à
découvrir dans le domaine de la couronne
roland lui aussi manier différentes
techniques du côté des arts plastiques
germa roses créé des oeuvres
monumentales pour faire don c'est la
couleur il a même créé des oeuvres
inédites pour son exposition à montigny
le bretonneux près de 1000 artistes dans
23 pays différents
et parmi eux un saint quentinois nicolas
salle expose à partir de demain une
sculpture lors de art paris art fair au
grand palais de paris
le rendez vous de l'art moderne et
contemporain et c'est une rencontre avec
les noms courtois que je vous propose un
reportage réalisé avec aurélie ronze des
poutrelles d'acier mastiquer et peintes
de couleurs blanches des lignes en chine
et cette pièce est réalisée en 2010 par
nicolas sale un sculpteur et donc pour
toi
elle fait partie d'une série de trois
dans les deux premières lignes sont
posés quasiment identiques et la
troisième ligne vient changer
la forme de la pièce et la perception de
la sculpture c'est une oeuvre qui qui
est sur un format horizontal due à la
période de deux voyages c'est dans le
nord à dunkerque où j'avais fait une
résidence et ceux qui n'avaient
intéressait c'était de réfléchir sur la
notion de l'espace mais pas dans la
verticalité mais d'un son horizontalité
vendredi 30 mars changement de
physionomie
les 800 kg de lèvres sont sur le départ
direction le grand palais à paris pour
une exposition d'art contemporain aux
grands pas la première fois il a soit
une semaine passionnante parce qu'on va
rencontrer des collectionneurs des
professionnels du public
on va pouvoir parler du travail la
visibilité
voilà c'est angie moment ils volent
semaine assez pauvre
pendant quatre jours nicolas sanhes
partagera le monument parisien avec
plusieurs autres artistes près 2000
créateurs participent à art paris art
faire des sculptures éphémères en
équilibre instable
une prestation qui bouscule notre
perception du réel avec se crée ton de
johann le guillerm créé un spectacle
phénomène en perpétuelle évolution
un rendez-vous à ne pas manquer dans le
domaine de la cour rolland a joué en
josas nous avons rencontré le créateur
et interprète jeune julien bonjour avec
secret vous explorez les lois de la
physique les équilibres fragiles c'est
bien ça oui entre autres mais je montre
des pratiques minoritaires d'un
dans l'espace des points de vue c'est à
dire des choses qui ne se font pas qui
ne se font plus qu'ils ne se sont jamais
fait et je montre ça sur une piste sous
ce chapiteau là derrière
[Musique]
comment vous est venue cette idée
comment on en est arrivé à développer
cette technique
alors ces techniques sont toutes issues
d'un observatoire autour du père grand
chose qui est un observatoire autour du
point à une époque je me suis j'ai voulu
faire un point sur mes croyances des
connaissances et j'ai ouvert un
observatoire autour du pot grand chose
donc est un observatoire à tour du point
en me disant que si j'arrive à
comprendre de quoi était fait pas grand
chose je retrouverai forcément ce pas
grand chose dans n'importe quelle chose
plus complexes et j'ai ouvert des
multiples chantiers en regardant ce
point qui m'ont amené à rencontrer
des choses comme la mathématique les
géométries la philosophie la topographie
et c'est donc tout toutes sortes de
choses comme je m'étais dit que si
j'arrivais à comprendre de quoi était
fait pas grand chose je retrouverai ce
minimale dans n'importe quelle chose
plus complexe c'est finalement ce qui
est arrivé mais à travers mon point de
vue et pas à travers une une
connaissance d'établi c'est à dire à
partir de ce que j'ai pu observer du
monde dans une réflexion très poussées
et très précises mais alors est-ce que
vous êtes un savant un chercheur ou un
circassien voix lors je suis
plus un plus un savant qu'un qu'un
scientifique mais quelque part je suis
plutôt un alchimiste non traditionnels
c'est à dire je suis pas issu de la
l'alchimie traditionnel mais demont
alchimie d'autodidacte
[Musique]
dans secrets vous évoluez avec
différentes matières de vous donner des
formes
quand est ce qu'elle vous résistez forme
de temps en temps est ce que vous avez
des idées vous rendez compte que ne
parvenait pas à les modifier
oui les choses saintes où résiste
j'essaye surtout d'être avec ces je suis
à l'écouté de la matière je suis à
l'écouté de ce qui se passe à l'instant
chaque jour c'est les choses sont
différentes agissent différemment
j'essaye d'être là chaque jour avec le
spectateur avec la température avec le
temps
l'instant vu cet entretien je ne
voudrais que le premier la première
partie du nom en fait de votre création
secret cette enquête en deux c'est fait
c'est une deuxième partie vous allez
commencer en 2013 et vous l'avez remis
peut-être au goût du jour en 2012 alors
c'est pas au goût du jour secrète un
spectacle en évolution depuis un certain
nombre d'années c'est à dire qu'à chaque
fois je fais une mutation je garde
impériale la moitié du spectacle qui se
renouvelle complètement
il ya un quart qui reste de l'ancien
spectacle et un quart qui revient du
précédent au dernier spectacle
perpétuelle évolution qui s'en sert
aussi dans une recherche globale
attraction c'est de ce dont tu parlais
au début c'est bien ça oui tout à fait
c'est à dire que là avec secrète en deux
on a une partie du projet attraction qui
est une petite partie de d'un ensemble
de travail de travaux qui vont de
de l'art plastique à la performance au
spectacle vivant aux conférences
pataphysique et bientôt un projet
culinaire et serrage investir domaine
assez large qui je cherche à délimiter
les les limites de mon espace de liberté
et vous demandez vous cherchez à face
que public s'interroge sur ce qu'il
devrait voir ce qu'ils ne voient pas ce
sur quoi ils ne s'arrêtent pas parfois
ce que je montre amène enfin je montre
des choses qu'on a plus l'habitude de
voir
après chacun un regard personnel qui
élit à son point de vue donc
certains oui on va percevoir des choses
qui n'ont pas l'habitude de voir parce
que
parce qu'ils s'arrêtent pas dessus parce
qu'ils n'ont jamais pensé les regarder
j'espère montrer à porter en tout cas
une forme de
de déstabilisation qui est qui et la
direction de mon travail
merci beaucoup johann le guillerm alors
secrétan de est à découvrir à partir du
31 mars jusqu'au 12 avril
germa roth ne se contente pas seulement
de peindre entre rigueur et chaos
l'artiste alsacien multiples et les arts
plastiques pour créer des oeuvres
monumentales des créations inédites à
découvrir au conservatoire des arts de
montigny le bretonneux nicolas
kirillovitch pour les images au détour
d'un coup de pinceau une sculpture
germain roesz mais ni les formes les
pigments et différentes techniques des
arts plastiques l'artiste fait danser la
couleur quand j'ai une couleur rouge par
exemple et que je veux un bleu je suis
obligé de passer à partir de la couleur
bleue rouge partout les par une dizaine
de couleurs pour arriver aux bleus et je
les pose sur la toile et donc vous avez
une espèce de continuité coloré une
chose comme une commune comme une ligne
continue comme ça qui se déroule dans la
dans la peinture ton chaque peinture
avec sa peinture il veut parler de
jubilation de plaisir immense germain
roesz fait de l'art monumental des
pièces de près de quatre mètres de haut
pensée pour le conservatoire des arts de
montigny le bretonneux
quand je suis venu voir le lieu il ya
plusieurs mois j'ai pris les mesures et
je tenais à le modifier par la taille
des pièces toutes ces pièces ont été
peintes en début d'année pour saint
quentin
savarese avait pas d'autres destinations
germain race conjugue son art à la
poésie une pensée qui se poursuit à la
médiathèque du canal avec une sélection
d'ouvragés jusqu'au 21 avril
pour le coup de coeur de la semaine on
prend la direction de saint cyr l'école
où bertrand pinet à quelques rendez vous
à vous donner
écoutez le coup de coeur du cinéma les
yeux d'elsa cette semaine ça n'est ni un
ni deux ni trois ni quatre films mais
six films nous participons cette année
comme depuis quatre ans au festival play
it again c'est un festival qui a pour
but de mettre en valeur les films du
patrimoine qui sont nombreux à sortir
sur les écrans français
tous les ans on a choisi donc 6 cette
année deux films français le trou de
jacques becker et qu'elle des enfants de
plus haut un film
pour les grands enfants et puis ceux qui
ont des souvenirs de ce film qui a été
un grand succès billy elliot de stephen
daldry des charlots et puis deux films
américains importants les moissons du
ciel de terrence malick le premier
chef-d'oeuvre de terrence malick mais
surtout mon petit chouchou
le lauréat de mike nichols qui a fait
découvrir au monde entier le talent de
dustin hoffman alors le lauréat c'est
cette histoire d'un jeune homme qui
vient de finir ses études et puis qui va
entrer dans une relation avec une femme
d'âge mûr et jouée par anne bancroft
évidemment plus compliquer quand tout à
coup son père lui demande de sortir
aussi avec la fille de cette dame ces
dames 5006 robinson
tout le monde connaît cette chanson de
simon and garfunkel toute la bo a été
fait par simon and garfunkel et voilà
c'est un très très beau film qui a
permis à mike nichols d'obtenir l'oscar
du meilleur réalisateur en 1968 qui sort
maintenant donc pour son 50e
anniversaire et que j'aurai le plaisir
de vous présenter le 20 avril en séance
unique à 20h30 lors d' une
ciné-conférence je vous attends donc au
cinéma national et ça pour le festival
play it again
c'est une première à maurepas une
semaine dédiée au cinéma israélien six
projections sont prévues au ciné cette a
et l'encours et à l'organisation le
comité de jumelage de maurepas et
l'association juive de maurepas et des
environs est avec nous en plateau nicole
malaquin et adeline sidorov on sort
alors vous êtes respectivement la
présidente et la vice présidente en
charge des relations avec israël
exact pour le comité de jumelage et
d'avoir la question est toute simple
comment vous est venue l'idée de parler
cette fois du cinéma et bien c'est une
idée qui nous est venue parce que cette
année l'état d'israël va fêter les 70
ans de sa création
et il fallait faire quelque chose pour
les mauraciens disons et puis pour les
environs évidemment aussi et
l'idée du cinéma nous est venue parce
qu'il ya des films très intéressant
israéliens sans doute peu connu par le
public français et nous avons pensé que
c'était c'était l'occasion de faire
connaître nos concitoyens voilà toute
l'histoire ne manque pas avec israël et
et anciennement non plus de l' intensité
20 ans il y à un jumelage avec tirât
carmel commence bien tout à fait sortie
95 voilà alors pareil nous sommes la
seule ville des yvelines à avoir un
jumelage avec une ville israélienne
et ça dure depuis 1995 et nous avons des
relations très suivies avec nos amis
d'israël donc à notre avis il fallait
faire quelque chose pour fêter les 70
ans de la création de l'état d'israël
des relations qui sont comment qui sont
artistiques qui sont culturelles les
deux alors nous avons surtout alors bien
sûr des rencontres entre amis on va dire
parce que c'est le but d'un jumelage
dans une commune évidemment il faut
essayer de faire se rencontrer des démos
repas indien et des gens de tirât carmel
mais nous avons aussi des musiciens qui
viennent et en particulier si on peut
parler de ça aujourd'hui aussi le du 24
juin vont venir un peu plus le var a
même à venir leur qu'istres de tirât
carmel et nous allons faire rencontrer
nos jeunes musiciens du conservatoire de
maurepas avec les musiciens de tirât
carmel
il y aura un concert commun le 21 juin
donc peut-être si vous voulez pas vous
en parler
cette occasion a justement ce que la pur
moment l'actualité qui est tout proche
ans que ça commence le 8 avril
c'est donc un festival de cinéma et le
cinéma israël est en fait très riche qui
multipliait qui multiplie les prix
depuis quelques années ce qui est une
politique qui a été mise en place en en
israël depuis 2001 et il ya des
récompenses à cannes à venise à césar et
c'est notamment le cas d'un
d'un film cas notamment je pense plus
marqué le public français c'est le
cochon de gaza qui a une césar du
premier film en 2012 et celui ci vont le
diffuser le 11 avril c'est bien ça oui
il est d'ailleurs il est déjà passé à la
télévision ou au moins deux fois
c'est un film assez drôle oui assez
cocasse quelques mots peut-être je
voudrais dire tout d'abord que il existe
des festi un festival du film israélien
à paris à paris depuis 18 ans qui fait
beaucoup de films qui prédit fils +38 ça
dure une semaine
il ya énormément de films de
documentaires également beaucoup et
cette année enfin il ya même des prix
qui sont décernés et cette année c'était
un hommage à ronit elkabetz plus une
grande actrice qui a disparu d'ailleurs
l'année dernière et alors bon nous avons
choisi des films que le public français
ne connaît pas forcément en dehors du
crosa et qui sont intéressants parce
qu'il montre la société israélienne et
est avec 1,1 point de vue un regard
parfois originales intéressants dont on
va parler à propos de chacun de ses
films a justement voir parce que je vous
parlais du cochon de gaza c'est le plus
connu
qu'est ce qui fait la particularité de
celui-là de celui-ci peut-être en plus
du césar c'est un film un petit peu
déroutant un peu drôle très drôle
d'ailleurs il ya qu'à voir les affiches
qui ont fait l'objet de ce film les
affiches de cinéma qui ont fait l'objet
de ce film je peux dire en dire quelques
mots
oui et justement après on regardera un
extrait pour se rendre pour accor alors
certaines situations un pêcheur
palestinien pauvre pêcheur palestinien
qui ramasse dans ses filets qui cueille
dans ses filets un cochon est un cochon
vietnamien tombé d'un cargo
alors il est très embarrassée parce que
évidemment le cochon est un animal impur
dans la religion musulmane et il ne sait
pas quoi en faire mais quand même il
voudrait bien en tirer partie alors il
va trouver une solution
peut-être pas nécessaire de révéler
parce qu'elle est rocambolesque ça fait
douter dans une situation un peu
compliquée
tout à fait et justement juste pour ce
contrôle je propose qu'on regarde
d'avoir un petit extrait
[Musique]
il faut absolument que tu leur jette par
dessus bord au dessus des gorges mais je
peux pas j'aurais dû sang impur sur les
mains si je les gans
[Musique]
ce sera sans talent je vous fasse entre
vous voulez vous que je fasse d'un port
lan shi nom veut dire nous les juifs
d'en face la barre il élève des cochons
je croyais que le bord c'était un
dernier aussi bien pour les juifs que
pour les jurys son patron et il trouve
toujours des solutions
enfin c'est un film qui parle de la
société actuelle il est tout récent mais
souvent aussi le cinéma israélien
s'inspire de son histoire une histoire
forte son histoire chargée depuis 70 ans
la shoah et 95 alors je tenais vous
l'avez pas nécessairement envie dans
votre festival
non on a on a choisi de le dernier film
un juif pour l'exemple parce que c'est
un film qui vient de sortir un à 14 mars
2010 voilà tout à fait donc on s'est dit
que c'était bien aussi d'avoir un film
qui vient de sortir et qui a un certain
rapport tout de même avec avec le
judaïsme les juifs l'histoire des juifs
plus exactement et mai mais ce n'est pas
un film vraiment israéliens et que
c'était précieux pour vous situer un peu
un contexte et stores et qui vous
permettait à maintien très dense est un
petit homme voilà il ya un lien bien
vieilli mais je n'ai pas un film
israélien est justement en parlant de
d'entrer dans cette culture aussi vous
avez choisi de diffuser tous les films
en vo
c'était important d'entendre oui cette
langue
oui c'était important puisque justement
ce sont des films israéliens où on peut
parler du cinéma israélien
ça a été d'ailleurs un peu compliqué
parce que il a fallu faire un choix
trouver des films qui étaient y avait
des sous titres et qu'on pouvait passer
parce qu'il ya énormément de films
israéliens et qu'elles sont pas traduits
actually ne sont pas traduits donc bon
ça nous à limiter un peu dans notre
choix de toute façon que ça et pour voir
un peu ça la culture vous avez deux
séances qui sont accompagnés de danses
folkloriques voilà parce que nous avons
une association culturelle à maurepas
qui s'appelle farandole et qui justement
dont la spécialité est de d'apprendre
des danses israélienne donc on a pensé
associer cette cette association à notre
festival et elles ont accepté avec
plaisir tous d'ailleurs je ne vais pas
la première fois qu'un jour une année
nous avions fêté un c'était
l'anniversaire des 20 ans du jumelage en
avait d'ailleurs un filou déjà mais
c'était dans un cadre beaucoup plus
restreint et la farandole avait déjà
dansé pour cette occasion très bien
merci à tous les oignons de la version
est donc pour se découvrir un peu plus
le cinéma israélien il se dévoile à
partir du 8 avril au ciné cette des
long-courriers votre partenaire est la
première projection a lieu à 18h15 avec
une semaine et un jour à guyancourt on
met à l'honneur des artistes du
territoire jusqu'au 29 avril la salle
d'exposition de la ville accueille art
talent le concours d'arts visuels de la
commune c'est la troisième édition de ce
rendez vous on écoute bénédicte ailier
coyne la maire adjointe en charge de la
culture de la ville
c'est vraiment divers complètement
toutes les esthétiques dont il ya de la
sculpture la peinture la photographie
mais ce qui était important c'est
d'avoir un regard de professionnel le
jury composé de deux professionnels et
le vendredi sera à rock à la batterie de
guyancourt sur scène mademoiselle k l'un
des visages du rock féminin français
elle était notre invité le 14 février
dernier écouter la relation de couple à
relation à devait la région avec les
autres m'intéresse beaucoup
et dans ce qui est nouveau dans cet
album c'est juste que c'est complètement
obsédé par la rupture et du coup c'est
que c'est vraiment le tout le fil rouge
de l'album c'est la rupture à part une
chanson un peu par qui s'appelle j'ai
pleuré qui parle plus d'eux
de l'amour et de la mort des êtres
proches et de notre rapport à eux
au delà de la mort et puis aussi de la
tristesse mais tout l'album est vraiment
axé sur la rupture et samaâ permet du
coup aussi de de ne pas trop me stresser
sur le style des morceaux que j'allais
faire taire et des moyens des morceaux
électro il ya des morceaux plus il ya
m'a justement j'ai pleuré qui est très
folk il ya des morceaux aussi plus rock
tout simplement
et aussi des morceaux en anglais des
morceaux en français parce que ça
faisait partie de cette histoire et est
en fait c'était pas un problème quoi
c'était du moment qu'il y avait ce cette
cohérence plus de rendre le propos est
dans et et dans la douce à vient en fait
c'est le dernier concert de la saison
pour les solistes de lavilledieu pour
l'occasion marianne piketty xavier
phillips invite trois jeunes musiciens
pour jouer lé quintette avec piano de
dvorak et brahms c'est un rendez vous
incontournable avec l'arrivée du
printemps les fontaines du château de
versailles reprennent du service
les grandes zones rouges avis dans les
jardins mais quel ennemi d'euros pour
les images uniques
c'est féerique majestueux ferme bio l'os
maison
elles font toujours briller les yeux ces
grandes eaux du château de versailles
depuis plus de 350 ans les 600 jeux
d'eau débute au printemps un ballet
majestueux préparé par les treize
fontenay
c'est toujours la même émotion d'offrir
à bien le travail de l'hiver où tout a
été entretenue réparé pour que l'année
2010 8 commence avec de belles zoé et va
durer toute la saison
[Musique]
au son de jean baptiste lully jean
philippe rameau et marc antoine
charpentier 55 fontaines et bassins
s'anime
parmi les nouveautés cette année le
bassin de neptune
[Musique]
le bassin neptune est un bassin qui est
le plus vaste avec son système de
fontaines ancien de tout le château est
un des plus vastes d'europe avec près de
150 mètres entre guillemets de dénivelé
de fond de dérouler de fontaine par
contre comme il consomme énormément
d'eau il ne peut être mise en doute très
rarement
donc on a trouvé un système automatisé
dans le centre du bassin là où il n'y a
pas de fontaine ancienne pour proposer
au public à cet endroit une activité
hydraulique qui ne soit pas celle de la
fontaine ancienne
avec plus de 100 représentations les
grandes zones jardins musicaux sont une
invitation à la promenade dans les pas
du roi soleil un instant suspendu qui
attire chaque année près de 12000
visiteurs par jour
m
avant de nous quitter quelques derniers
rendez vous à noter du côté de plaisir
vous pourrez parler littérature
l'association lecture et dialogues
organise une rencontre avec marie hélène
lafon l'écrivain échangera à propos de
son ouvrage nos vies et romain gary sans
doute pas besoin de présenter ses
ouvrages mon connaît peut-être un peu
moins son histoire la compagnie les
anges au plafond vous entraîne dans les
années 60 aux etats unis quand l'auteur
et sa femme recueille un chien abandonné
capable d'une extrême sauvagerie sa
guérison est à découvrir samedi 7 avril
et au prisme
on accueille un clown féroce gilles
ostrowski transforme librement la
légende des atrides une ligne est
maudite les fureurs dos trop ce qui
passe au tragique sanglant au comique
plein de dérision
extraits
[Musique]
m
mua
bon
màj màj
[Musique]
oui
et c'est la fin de ce set une culture je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mercredi prochain
[Musique]